c'est sa première alors qu'il goûte à
tous les manèges sera pas cette année ce
sera l'année prochaine
que ce soit pour une balade en famille
ou des sensations fortes entre amis la
fête des loges à plein de ressources
pour cette 367e les visiteurs peuvent
découvrir plus de 200 animations stands
jeux et bien sûr les traditionnels
manèges
je pense que c'est merveilleux c'était
génial vraiment génial et bien c'est
quoi c'est plus convivial que la foire
du trône qui est très grande a fait
lâcher un peu plus convivial et on
respire
si certains sont venus pour un moment de
détente d'autres ont bien sûr profité de
la visite en forêt de saint germain en
laye pour monter dans les attractions
les plus impressionnantes et le courage
n'est pas à bloc chez tout le monde
alors moi j'ai pas bien pas les
sensations fortes j'ai peur donc je leur
laisse aller jusque 12 ans comme ça
justement des sensations fortes ou on
aime ça donc on choisit les manèges les
plus attentionnés
c'est la première et la seule en tant
que wayne on la sait quoi ça nous a
retourné un petit peu le coeur mais
c'est sympa vous avez jusqu'au 18 août
pour profiter de la fête des loges plus
de deux millions de visiteurs sont
attendus sur place cités